in this lesson we're going to talk about
an introduction to trigonometry so what
exactly is trigonometry well trig refers
to Triangle metri refers to like the
measurements in a triangle the sides of
the triangle the angles in a triangle
and what we're going to go through is
we're going to go through the
trigonometric ratios the sine cosine and
tangent and what those mean we're going
to talk about an acronym sohcahtoa which
helps us to find the sine cosine and
tangent a little bit more easily we're
going to solve for missing sides in the
triangles as well as missing angles
we're going to do what's called solving
the right triangle and we're going to
also mention about angle of elevation
angle of depression so we'll go through
some problems I'll have some examples
you can practice on your own but the
first thing to ask ourselves is what
exactly is the sine that cosine and the
tangent now you can see they're written
here in their full form but we
oftentimes abbreviate them with the
first three letters so we say s i n for
sine cos for cosine and tan and for
tangent and if you see this little Greek
symbol here Theta that just refers to
the angle so when we talk about the sine
of an angle what we're talking about is
the ratio of two sides in a right
triangle so if we say what's the sign of
an angle it's the opposite side over the
hypotenuse the cosine is the adjacent
side over the hypotenuse and the tangent
is the ratio of the opposite side over
the adjacent side now an acronym that
can help us to remember this is This
Acronym and the way I like to think of
it is s is for sine C is for cosine and
T is for tangent and it's always the
second letter divided by the third so
what I mean by that is the sign is the
opposite side divided by the hypotenuse
the cosine is the adjacent side divided
by the hypotenuse and the tangent is the
opposite side divided by the adjacent
side so if you can just write that down
and remember
you're halfway there here so let's look
at an introductory example say we have
this right triangle right here 5 12 and
13 represent the side lengths and we
want to figure out what's the sine of
angle a now what I like to do is in my
mind just kind of picture like I'm
standing at this angle right here at
this vertex and what you want to think
of is the sine is the opposite side over
the hypotenuse so opposite means the
side that's across from the angle so
that's going to be 5
over the hypotenuse which the hypotenuse
is always the side across from the right
angle so that's going to be 5 over
13 and that's your sine ratio now we're
going to talk about how to use those
ratios to solve for things and then
coming problems okay but let's go
through this introduction first so the
cosine now we're going to say cosine is
the adjacent side over the hypotenuse
now if you're working with angle a
adjacent side would be the side next to
that Angle now you might be saying Mario
isn't this 13 right here is in this side
also next to this angle and that's true
but the one across from the right angle
we always call that the hypotenuse so
the adjacent side would be the other
side that's next to the angle but not
the hypotenuse so again cosine is
adjacent meaning next to the angle
divided by the hypotenuse that's the one
across from the right angle so this is
going to be 12 over 13. that's our
cosine ratio for angle a now tangent
is this TOA which is the opposite side
over the adjacent side so if we're here
at angle a remember opposite is across
adjacent is next to so it's going to be
the opposite
5 over the adjacent 12 and you've got it
now let's switch our perspectives now
let's pretend like we're over here at
angle B
okay let's erase our first guy there and
let's say we want to find the sine of
angle B so for here at this angle the
sine remember it's the opposite divided
by the hypotenuse now here are the
opposite we have to go across so
opposite is going to be 12.
over the hypotenuse which is always the
one across the right angle which is 13.
so our sine of angle B is 12 over 13.
now what about the cosine of angle B
well the cosine
that's the adjacent over the hypotenuse
so here the adjacent is going to be the
one next to the angle 5
over the hypotenuse which is 13. now
again don't get confused when you think
of next two see 13 and 5 are both next
to that angle right but we want the one
that's not a hypotenuse okay and then
the last one the tangent of angle B
that's going to be opposite over
adjacent so that's going to be 12 over
5.
and you got it let's take a look at
another example okay for this example
number two see if you can practice this
one on your own go ahead and pause the
video draw a diagram here use your
sohcahtoa acronym and find the sine of
angle D cosine of angle D tangent of
angle D then switch to angle e and find
the sine cosine and tangent of angle e
now if I was going to do it what I would
do is I'd start with sine of angle D
which is this angle right here
and I would position myself at that
angle so I'd say to myself okay I'm
right here at angle D and I want the
sine which is the ratio of the opposite
side over the hypotenuse now when I
think of opposite I think of the side
across that's going to be eight divided
by the hypotenuse which is always the
one that's across from the right angle
that's going to be the 17.
now if we want to do the cosine of angle
D again we're over here at this vertex
angle D cosine is the ratio of the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse
adjacent means next to that's 15 and the
hypotenuse is the one across from the
right angle that's 17.
and if we want to find the tangent of
angle D we are going to use the TOA
acronym and that's the opposite side
over the adjacent side so from angle D
opposite would be 8
adjacent would be 15.
and you've got it now let's switch over
to angle e so what we're going to do is
we're going to position ourself at this
vertex okay and we're going to say
what's the sign of angle e it's the
ratio of the opposite side over the
hypotenuse so from angle e opposite
would be a cross like this that would be
15.
over the hypotenuse which is always the
one across in the right angle 17. the
cosine of angle e we're going to use Ka
which is the adjacent over the
hypotenuse so adjacent means next to
over the hypotenuse which is the one
across the right angle so that's going
to be 8 over 17. now remember adjacent
17 and 8 are both adjacent or next to
angle e but we want the one that's not
the hypotenuse not the one that's across
from the right angle so adjacent would
be eight hypotenuse would be 17 and then
lastly the tangent of angle e this is
the ratio of the opposite over the
adjacent so opposite would be 15.
adjacent would be the one next to which
is eight and you got it okay for these
next few problems we're going to talk
about how to solve for the missing side
so this is where you are get into some
application and how do you actually
utilize the sine cosine and tangent to
help you to solve for a missing side so
what you want to do here is you want to
position yourself at the angle so you'd
say okay they're giving me this 40
degree angle in a right triangle so I'm
going to position myself you don't have
to draw the stick figure but you just
pretend like you're at this vertex and
then you say to yourself what sides am I
working with well I've got the opposite
side which I'm trying to solve for and
the hypotenuse now you only want one
variable one unknown so when I think of
the opposite and the hypotenuse opposite
and hypotenuse tells us about the sine
ratio so we're going to say the sign
of 40 degrees equals remember it's
always the second over the third it's
the opposite side which is X over the
hypotenuse which is the one across the
right angle 10.
now if you try to do the tangent like
opposite and adjacent you'd have two
variables so you wouldn't be able to
solve for this unknown so you just want
one variable one unknown so that you can
solve for it now we want to get X by
itself what's the opposite of dividing
by 10 well that would be to multiply
both sides of this equation by 10. don't
multiply the 40 by 10 and make that 400
just put the 10 in front of the sign and
now you can see we have 10 times the
sine of 40. now you're going to need a
scientific calculator or in this case
I'm just using a graphing calculator but
we're going to type this in 10 sine of
40. the other thing you want to make
sure of is make sure that you're in
degrees and not radians so you might
have to go to your mode check your that
you're in degrees so 10 times the sine
of 40 degrees I'm just going to round to
the nearest tenth that comes out to 6.4
so I'll just say approximately 6.4 is
the length of that side okay let's look
at number four now
so for number four this angle is what
we're dealing with here so let's
position ourselves at the 65 degree
angle and we want to ask ourselves what
ratio sine cosine or tangent ties
together the opposite side and the
adjacent side
well opposite and adjacent that's our
tangent that's our TOA so we're going to
say the tangent of 65 degrees so it's
always sine cosine or tangent of the
angle equals the ratio of the second
divided by the third in this case the
opposite 7 over the adjacent which is y
now we want to get that variable by
itself right so what I'm going to do
here is to get rid of this fraction
instead of dividing by y I'm going to
multiply both sides by y that way these
cancel one another out but we're trying
to get y by itself so instead of
multiplying by tangent of 65 let's
divide both sides by the tangent of 65.
that way those cancel we have y by our
itself we're going to divide this side
by tangent of 65 as well keep it
balanced so what we have is y equals 7
divided by tangent of 65. so I'm going
to go to the calculator 7 divided by
tangent of 65 I'm going to round to the
nearest tenth you should be getting y
equals 3.3
and that's this missing side now let's
look at number five same idea we're
going to position ourselves at this
angle 38 you can draw the little stick
figure if you want and you think okay
what side is this that's adjacent see
next to and what side is this that's
across from the right angle that's the
hypotenuse adjacent and hypotenuse is
our cosine ratio so we're going to say
the cosine of our angle cosine of 38
degrees
equals the ratio of the adjacent divided
by the hypotenuse so adjacent we said
was X hypotenuse we said was across from
the right angle 8 to get X by itself
instead of dividing by eight let's do
the opposite let's multiply both sides
by eight so X is equal to 8 times the
cosine of 38 we'll go to the calculator
and I'm getting about 6.3 so 6.3 is
equal to X that's that missing side okay
for number six seven and eight see if
you can pause the video and attempt
these problems on your own we'll go
through them together but it's good to
practice just to make sure you really
have a feel for it before we move on to
solving for the missing angle so here
we're solving for the missing side what
would you do for number six seven and
eight well if I was going to do number
six what I would do is I would position
myself at the angle here that they're
giving us 17 degrees and I look at I've
got the opposite side and I have the
adjacent side so remember opposite and
adjacent tells us that it's the tangent
ratio so we're going to say tangent
of the angle 17 degrees equals the
opposite divided by the adjacent so
that's going to be 9 over X now another
way to do this problem and solve for x
is to think of this as being over one
because anything divided by 1 is itself
and a shortcut if you like shortcuts and
this is a property of proportions is you
can actually interchange these on the
diagonals you could put X over here in
tangent of 17 over here that's a quick
way to get X by itself because x divided
by 1 is just X
but some students are not so comfortable
with that so what you might want to do
is just cross multiply you probably
learned this when you learn about
proportions the cross product so you'd
say x times the tangent of 17.
equals 9 times 1 which is 9. we want to
get X by itself so instead of
multiplying by tangent of 17 let's
divide both sides by the tangent of 17.
and these cancel so let's see let's go
to the calculator 9 divided by the
tangent of 17.
comes out to and I'm just rounding a
little bit here to the nearest tenth so
let's say 29.4 so this is 29
.4
okay number seven let's try this one now
so what did you do on this problem well
again I like to kind of draw my little
stick figure person here and then I
think to myself okay this is the angle
and I've got the adjacent side which is
the next two and the one across from the
right angle which is the hypotenuse so
when I'm thinking adjacent and
hypotenuse we're thinking of the cosine
ratio so that's going to be the cosine
of 22 degrees equals second letter over
third adjacent over hypotenuse
and now we're going to do is we can do
that little trick where we can cross
multiply or switch these on the diagonal
so whichever one you're most comfortable
with or if you don't like either of
those you can do what we did earlier
which is to multiply both sides by X
those cancel now we have x times the
cosine of 22 degrees equals 13 but we
want to get X by itself so instead of
multiplying by cosine of 22
we're going to do divide by cosine of
both sides by 22 degrees and now you can
see 13 divided by cosine of 22 gives us
X and that is about
14.0 if we round to the nearest tenth
okay and then for number eight what did
you do for this one
well again if I was going to do it I put
my little stick figure I just kind of
pretend like I'm standing here at this
vertex and I say okay I've got this
angle the opposite side and the one
across from the right angle which is the
hypotenuse opposite in hypotenuse is the
sine so we're going to say the sine of
the angle 50 degrees equals the opposite
which is X over the hypotenuse which is
17 and then instead of dividing by 17
what we'll do is we'll multiply both
sides by 17 so that we get X by itself
so what is 17 times the sine of 50.
let's do that on the calculator
okay and that's coming out to about
13.0 and one other thing I just want to
point out real quick because sometimes
if you're having a little bit of trouble
with this still what you might want to
do and some students like to do this is
when as soon as you set up your triangle
and you position yourself you might
actually want to write okay across uh
opposite maybe put an O and then you say
okay across into the right angle that's
the hypotenuse H so then really all I'm
left with is a right that's the only
other we only have opposite adjacent
hypotenuse but we know Jason is next to
then when you look at it you say Okay
opposite and hypotenuse I can see I only
have one unknown here so yeah opposite
hypotenuse that's going to give me my
sine ratio and then you can proceed from
there instead of having to remember it
in your mind okay for number 9 10 and 11
what we're going to do is we're going to
solve for the missing Angle now so a
little bit different from the last few
problems what you want to do is you're
still going to be working with your sine
cosine and tangent ratios but we're
going to be doing the inverse sine
inverse cosine and inverse tangent it so
what you're going to do is you're going
to position yourself at the angle like
we've been doing and you're going to be
saying to yourself okay this angle we've
got the side opposite and we have the
side adjacent and remember opposite and
adjacent that's our tangent but what
we're going to do now is we're going to
say the tangent of
X degrees equals the opposite divided by
the adjacent so opposites across
adjacent is next to we want to get X by
itself so what you can do is you can
take the tangent inverse
which is represented by this little
minus 1 here of both sides of the
equation so tangent inverse and what
happens is these undo one another so it
gives us our angle by itself so X
degrees is equal to the tangent inverse
of opposite over adjacent now you could
skip that first step if you want as you
do this more and more just realize that
if you're solving for the angle you're
going to use the inverse sine or inverse
cosine or inverse tangent now on your
calculator you might need to press the
second key okay and it should be right
above your sine cosine and tangent keys
so it should be second tan so that's tan
inverse of 10 divided by 12. each
calculator is a little bit different you
might have to play around with yours a
little bit and kind of find out where
that's located if you're doing it on a
smartphone it's a little bit different
as well so just play around a little bit
with that but this is how you would
solve so this would be 39.8 degrees now
we're solving for for the angle right so
for number 10 let's look at this one
we're going to position ourself at the
angle and it looks like we're given the
opposite side and the hypotenuse because
it's across from the right angle
again remember you can label it as O A
and H okay so we want to find this angle
we're given opposite and hypotenuse that
sine but since we're solving for the
angle we're going to do the sine inverse
of the opposite over the hypotenuse
again we're going to go to the
calculator I'm going to press the second
key sine inverse of 2 divided by 9 and
I'm getting about 12
0.8 degrees okay that's this angle right
here and then number 11 again we're
going to position ourself at the angle
and it looks like we have the adjacent
side and the hypotenuse and you can see
adjacent and hypotenuse that's our
cosine but because we're solving for the
angle we're going to use our inverse
cosine or our cosine inverse of adjacent
over hypotenuse now remember the ratios
are still the same just because you're
doing the inverse they're still going to
do second over third second letter over
third and cosine inverse of 5 divided by
cosine inverse of 5 11 which comes out
to
63.0 degrees if you round to the nearest
tenth so that's that angle right there
okay number 12 13 and 14. see if you can
do these problems on your own pause the
video draw these diagrams write down
your sohcahtoa acronym and see if you
can solve the for these missing angles
now while you do that I just want to
mention that if you like my teaching
style I have an Algebra 2 video course
for sale that goes more into
trigonometry and goes into college
algebra topics so if that's something
you're interested in I'll put a link in
the description below check that out but
let's dive into these examples now if I
was going to solve this
I would position my stick figure here at
the angle and I would say to myself what
am I working with I'm working with my
opposite side and my hypotenuse so that
tells me that this is my sign
ratio and because I'm solving for the
missing angle I'm going to use the sine
inverse of the opposite divided by the
hypotenuse which is going to be the 4
over 18. now if we go to the calculator
this is coming out to
12.8 degrees
okay for number 13 what did you get for
this one well again I would position
myself at the angle and I'm looking at
the ratio of the opposite side and the
adjacent side so that's telling me that
it's the tangent and because we're
solving for the missing angle we're
going to use the tangent inverse so
that's opposite over adjacent for
tangent so if we do that on the
calculator
that is coming out to
39.8 degrees
and we're going to go into number 14 and
we've got some more problems after this
as well we're going to talk about
solving right triangles and also a
little bit about angle of elevation
angle depression so stick around for
that if I was doing this one I would
position myself at the angle it looks
like we have adjacent and hypotenuse so
X is going to equal the cosine inverse
the adjacent hypotenuse of the adjacent
over the hypotenuse 1 4 so that's going
to be cosine inverse of 1 4 and I'm
getting an angle of
75.5 degrees approximately and you've
got that one okay for number 15 and 16
we're going to talk about solving the
right triangle what that means is you're
solving the entire triangle you're
finding all the Angles and all the sides
so I'll do number 15 and kind of show
you how this works you can try number 16
on your own we'll also go through that
one together so let's dive into number
15.
now the question is what should we solve
for first well it looks like they're
giving us two sides of this right
triangle so we can solve for this third
side I think I'm going to do that first
and I'm going to use the Pythagorean
theorem we haven't done that yet in this
video but remember in a right triangle
you probably remember this from algebra
one a squared plus b squared equals c
squared so it means the sum of the two
legs squared the sides that make up the
right angle okay those squared add up to
the hypotenuse squared which is the one
across from the right angle so if we do
this we can see that we're going to get
7 squared plus Z squared is equal to our
hypotenuse squared which is 25 squared
so if we do that we get 49 plus Z
squared equals 625 if we subtract 49
from both sides we get
576 and if we take the square root of
both sides we get 24. so you can see now
we've got all three sides we want to
solve for the the angles now so say if I
wanted to solve for this angle X now
what I'd like to do and you might want
to do this too is I tend to go back to
the original numbers that they gave me
because they're exact they're not maybe
rounded in this case 24 came out nice
and even but say if I made a mistake on
a quiz or test and I use this number and
it was wrong and then I carry that
mistake forward so if you can try to go
back to the original numbers that'll
help out a lot so now if I want to find
this angle X here I can see that I've
got the
opposite in the hypotenuse so that's the
sign but because we're solving for angle
X we're going to do the sine inverse so
X is equal to the sine inverse of
opposite over hypotenuse so 7 over
25. so let's do that on the calculator
sine inverse is 7 over 25 that's coming
out to about
16.3 so I'm just going to label this
here 16.3 degrees and these two angles
the two acute angles in a right triangle
they always add up to 90 degrees because
90 Plus 90 is 180. so a quick way to do
this is just take 90 minus 16.3
and that gives you the other angle which
is 73
0.7 degrees and now you solve the
triangle you found all three angles all
three sides it's solved so see if you
can pause the video and do number 16 on
your own looks like we're solving for
this side a this side C and this angle y
so go ahead and try that one and while
you do that if you like the way that I'm
explaining things and you're like this
Mario guy of Mario's math tutoring like
I get how he explains this stuff you
know it's because I tutor students every
day you know full time working with
students in my local district and so I
try to incorporate things that I see
students struggle with and to these
videos to kind of show you how to avoid
some of the same mistakes and make
things a little bit easier so if you
like that
you know go ahead and follow me on this
channel but let's dive into number 16
here so this one what we're going to do
is we're going to find out this side
right here and the way I'm going to do
that is I'm just going to use this angle
this side and this side so that's the
opposite and adjacent which speaks to
the tangent ratio right so we're going
to say the tangent
of 25 degrees is equal to 8 over a now
I'm going to multiply both sides by a to
get rid of the
fraction there and then I'm going to
divide both sides by tangent of 25 to
get this a by itself so it looks like a
is going to equal 8 divided by the
tangent of 25 degrees let's see what
that comes out to
8 divided by tangent of 25 and that's
about
17.2 so let's put that right here and
now angle y this one's pretty easy
because we already have these two angles
we could add them up and subtract from
180 or the two acute angles add up to
90. so 90 minus 25 is going to be 65
degrees and now I could do the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus b
squared equals c squared and find that
hypotenuse but this is a rounded number
so I'm going to go back to the original
numbers which are the 25 and the eight
so it looks like I have the opposite
and the hypotenuse which is the sine so
we're going to do is we're going to do
the sine of 25
degrees
equals the opposite over the hypotenuse
which we called PSI C so now what you
can do is you can cross multiply or on
this last problem since I'm running out
of space here I'm just going to use the
little shortcut method I mentioned
earlier where you can switch these on
the diagonal so I'm going to put C here
C over 1 is C is equal to 8 divided by
the sine of 25 so let's see what that
comes out to
okay and I am getting about 18.9 so
that's
that third side so now you solve the
triangle you found all the angles all
the sides let's take a look at some
story problems some angle of elevation
angle depression problems next okay now
what we want to do is we want to bring
this trigonometry into the real world we
want to say how do we actually use
trigonometry to help us in real life
right so that's where the angle
elevation angle of depression can come
in and what I want to point out is uh
angle of elevation is basically like
you're standing here and you're
elevating or you're looking up okay to
that line of sight so in this example
here you can kind of like think of that
angle of elevation as up from the
horizontal now angle of depression
you're looking down okay from the
horizontal like this so that would be
this angle right here so whenever you're
doing an angle of elevation or angle
depression problem you can always draw
like this rectangle like I'm drawing
here and the angle of elevation angle
depression those are actually going to
be congruent they're alternate interior
angles because these lines are parallel
and you probably remember that from
geometry right so now what you want to
do is you want to realize that this
length and this length are the same this
side and this side are the same and so
you can use that to your advantage to
realize that there's two triangles here
sometimes students get a little bit
confused when they see a triangle they
think of this is the angle of depression
but you always want to go down from the
horizontal elevation up from the
horizontal so let's take a look at
number 17 and 18 I'll do 17 maybe you
can see if you can do number 18 on your
own
say for example you want to find the
height of a tree like a pine tree what
you could do is you could walk back from
that pine tree like a hundred feet
look at your angle of elevation you
might take a protractor or estimate you
know approximate what that angle of
elevation is to the top of the tree then
what you can do is you can say all right
I'm going to find this height of this
tree it's a lot safer than actually
climbing the tree with a tape measure
right so you're on the ground so you say
well what trig function ties together
this angle this side and this side well
it looks like we have opposite and
adjacent that's our TOA which means that
this is going to be the tangent
of 58 degrees is equal to the opposite
side over the adjacent side so if we
multiply both sides by a hundred
that's going to give us the height by
itself so let's do that on the
calculator 100 times the tangent of 58
comes out to about 160 okay so that
means this tree is about 160 feet
tall okay now for number 18 see if you
can do this one imagine if you're flying
a kite okay and you let out 300 feet of
string and you approximate that angle of
elevation to be 65 degrees how high is
the kite above the ground now the one
thing that we're missing here on this
problem and I'll this adds another layer
of complexity is imagine if you're
holding the string like at maybe waist
level or so see this might be three feet
above the ground right where you're
holding the string so when you get this
height you'll have to add three to it to
get you know the actual height above the
ground but in this case we're mainly
working with the triangle but just an
added step We'll add an additional three
feet to get the
direct height of the kite above the
ground so what would you do for that one
go ahead and pause the video if I was
going to do it I would see that I have
the opposite side
and the hypotenuse so that tells me
opposite in hypotenuse that's the sign
so that's going to be the sine of 65
degrees is equal to the opposite over
the hypotenuse and instead of dividing
by 300 we're going to multiply both
sides by 300
and so let's see what that comes out to
on the calculator 300 sine of 65. it
looks like it's a
271.9 if we want to add the 3 feet on
here
that's going to be about
274.9 or about 275 feet above the ground
so great job if you want to see more
examples you want more practice you want
to see me explain more about
trigonometry I'll put a video right
there talking about introduction to
trigonometry like a basic trigonometry
Basics so follow me to that video there
we'll do some more practice and I'll see
you in that video